[موسيقى]
مرحبا اسمي ياسمين ادريس وانا اول امراه
عربيه وسعوديه بتلف حوالين بلد ايسلند عن
طريق
[موسيقى]
الدراجه دربت لمده ارب ل خمس شهور تدريب
خاص سته ايام في اسبوع اربعه ايام كانت
على الدراجه ويومين في النادي والهدف من
التدريب كان اني ازيد من لياقه جسمي عشان
يتحمل ساعات طويله على الدراجه اكبر
التحديات اللي واجهتها كانت عباره عن
تحديات جسديه ونفسيه بالنسبه
للتحديات الجسديه كانت مواجهه الرياح
القويه اللي صعبت علي المهمه اكثر شيء
وخلتني اطيح من الدراجه احيانا مع انه كنت
كت متوقعه انه الجو يكون عائق وصعب ما
فكرت اني اتابع تقرير عن الطقس او
التضاريس او اجهز استراتيجيه بس اتعلمت
درسي بسرعه وبالنسبه للتحديات النفسيه في
البدايه كان الموضوع صعب اني امضي ساعات
طويله لوحدي في بلد فاضي تماما من الناس
بس الحمد لله بعدين تحول الموضوع ل تمل في
حياتي وفهم اعمق لنفسي وتصف افكاري كل يوم
كان عندي خيار يا اقدر احاول اتغلب على
الطبيعه والارض اللي حوالي او اقدر الاقي
طرق اني اتعاون معاها وانسجم مع الطبيعه
عشان اسهل على
نفسي الموضوع ولما غيرت تفكيري من دي
الناحيه فعلا تغيرت المهمه واقدر اقول
بثقه انه غيرت لي حياتي الرحله هذه حسيت
اني كاني تولدت من جديد من خلال
[موسيقى]
الرحله